Now we are ready to finish off our parser.
There were three ways to add to the chart, and you've already done one and two,
computing the closure or predicting what's happening next and shifting.
The last way is reductions.
Let's say once again that we're looking at chart i,
and one element of it is the state x goes to ab dot cd coming from j.
I'm going to write this code. I'll lock it into our parser.
Next_states equals reductions, a function that gets to look at the chart, i, x, ab, cd, and j.
It's going to return a list of possible next states.
For each one, we will add it to the chart and notice if anything changed.
Reductions are relatively tricky,
so my first hint for you is you only want to do reductions if cd is empty.
Remember reductions only apply if the red dot is as far right as possible.
My other hint for you is that you'll have to look back previously at the chart.
Remember when we worked through examples together, we'd start over here,
go back over the chart, and then go back to the right.
You'll have to do the same sort of thing, so we're passing in the chart.
Try it out. This one's a bit tricky.